all right now this is pretty
straightforward seeing as though the
calling code has given us an x and y
value of where to exist in the world we
simply pass those through to the entity
definition object next we actually
determine the half width and the half
height of the bounding box for this
object now for the simple projectile
class that we're using here we
statically defined its width and height
25 units of course passing half of that
to the right variable in addition we
also set the surface parameter of
dampening 20 now in order to facilitate
as a debugging aid for our purposes we
pass in an ID object to the entity
definition now inside the add body
method we attach this ID properly so
that later on we can identify this
object differential from everything else
this helps with debugging and
determining whether or not it's a
missile hitting you in the forehead or a
rubber chicken